let me begin by introducing our speakers
bill marks is the editor of Arts fuse an
online magazine that covers the Arts in
New England and he's also the editor of
the book of the world book page about
international literature for the BBC
program the world in 2002 bill created
and edited the WBUR online arts edited
wbur online arts a cultural webzine that
one in online an award for online
journalism in 2004 and in two thousand
five bills weekly column on the website
was a finalist for the online journalism
award for online commentary he's written
about books about about he's written
about books and theater for the Boston
Globe and the Boston Phoenix and a
number of national publications he
currently teaches a class at Boston
University on american arts criticism
that follows the evolution of reviewing
from the 19th century until today my
hope is that we'll hear a bit from Bill
about that interest in the in
essentially the continuities across
media and across and across cultures I'd
also like to welcome some of bill's
students who have attended this session
I'm glad to see you here I hope this
won't be the first time the only time
you appear at a communications forum
event if you're interested in signing up
for our for our web notifications for
our email notifications I encourage you
to do so by signing up on our website we
never use that email list for anything
except announcements about the forum so
you won't be inundated with the
irrelevant emails our second speaker
Doug mclennan is the founder and editor
of arts journal com a leading aggregator
of arts journalism on the internet
before starting arts journal Doug was
arts columnist and music critic for the
Seattle post-intelligencer he earned his
master's degree in music from the
Juilliard School in New York and was
named one of the 100 outstanding
graduates of the Juilliard School for
the school centennial in 2005
doug has written on the arts for many
publications including work as a music
critic in the early days of salon and
has written also for Newsweek the New
York Times the Los Angeles Times and The
Wall Street Journal so both of our
speakers have have a special claim on
our on our broad topic and indeed it
isn't a very broad topic essentially
what is happening to what we broadly
call arts criticism let me start with a
brief definition we can confuse the
definition or complicated or or alter it
in our discussion but broadly what we
mean by arts criticism is discourse
about art dance drama prose fiction
poetry discourse about the Arts in our
culture and where that this course is
located where that discourse is
migrating that's our broadest our broad
topic so let me begin by asking each of
our speakers first to begin with a
couple of comments about the way they
feel the condition the what they feel
about the sort of state or nature of
what we're broadly calling arts
criticism in the era before the Internet
the first I just want to thank you want
to talk about what I thought arts
criticism was like before the Internet
well I mean it's a large question but
essentially you know look if you take it
let's say in America from the 19th
century on I mean arts criticism in
America played a pivotal role in a
number of major newspapers and magazines
for helping define the culture for
helping to send people to or away from
various performances of the read books
or not or not to read books so
essentially it was a form of editorial
evaluative discourse that was found in a
you know some of the better newspapers
and magazines certainly in the early
19th century it was a highly corrupt
practice at that point there were no
editorial standards someone like Edgar
Allan Poe was writing the 1830s and
1840s you know essentially when they
would send out a book for review they'd
send out a five-dollar bill in the book
indicating of course and five dollars is
a lot in the 1830s in the 1840s it was a
really in the late 19th century that
editorial standards began to be applied
to criticism that partly because
newspapers and magazines wanted to go
for a tone your audience in other words
if you were writing about museums you've
read about symphony orchestras and the
assumption was that you're going to have
critics that would have the expertise
have the knowledge and would have the
ethics to cover them and you also had
like the Atlantic Monthly and Harper's
and a number of other Tony magazines you
know begin about at that time become
extremely popular so the the rules for
criticism the definition of criticism
began to be codified then and I guess I
would add to your definition of what
what arts criticism is by saying for me
the definition of Arts criticism is
going to be is an evaluation with
reasons meaning that even in the time of
edgar allan poe poe said a review was a
valuation of something it was a judgment
but you have you evaluated by the
reasons that were provided by the critic
so in other words a review from the 19th
century until today and now perhaps that
definition is beginning to weaken a bit
the definition was a judgment which was
backed up by evaluation and reasons so
if you want to move into the United keep
moving back in the in the past but i
would say that essentially if you to say
what was the old-fashioned idea of what
a criticism was obviously was written it
was in a newspaper in a magazine it was
written by someone perceived to be an
expert a judge and it was supposed to
supply some sort of reasoning behind how
this judge came to their evaluation and
that began to change I'd say generally
in the nineteen around the turn of the
century in the 1920s in the 20s with the
oncoming of popular culture popular
culture came about and there were
prescribed ideas of what was a great
symphony orchestra what would they
playing over the what was great music
great painting but with jazz with radio
with a lot of other more popular culture
films in particular than those that
those sorts of ideas scrambled the idea
of what criticism was supposed to be and
tampered with or dealt with that
essential idea of
valuation with reason how about you you
wish me to go on or not and I'll move up
to the present or move up to the 40s 50s
60s or what would you like all right
lost a lot of conversation about the
argument about what we're losing what
we're gaining in terms of arts criticism
these days is that we we do need to a
lot of us think about a kind of a golden
age of arts criticism where the
newspapers have full staffs and they
have critics and and you know we're
talking about this this kind of
evaluative process the reality is in
most of this country though that most
newspapers did not have that kind of
thing up until about the 1970s so even
cities in of the size of Minneapolis or
Seattle or salt lake city or a lot of
the cities in the West it was very rare
for them to have a full critical staff
and that's that's largely a phenomenon
beginning in the late 70s early 80s so
this shrinking down of arts staffs at
newspapers is actually in a way kind of
going back to what we had pre seventies
I would sort of agree you know I'd agree
with that I would say that you had
centralized newspapers it's late we
still have the New York Times The New
Yorker magazine perhaps on the west
coast as well their criticism was
republished or sent to newspapers around
the country so when someone reviewed New
York theater and you're in Indiana or
wherever you were Alabama you would
often read the reviews up or get
knowledge of what was going on in those
centers of culture through the critics
you wrote for the large newspapers
they're often syndicated and sent around
that's why they didn't need the higher
and art staff basically if they need to
plug their art their art hole they would
have syndicated material from some of
the larger newspapers and magazines so
people were aware of what criticism was
but by having it set from you know from
some of the larger newspapers and
magazines and they represented an ideal
of what
criticism should be and often in
practice that's not what you saw in a
lot of newspapers and magazines around
the country but I'm talking about sort
of like what critics at their best saw
themselves is doing right wouldn't you
also say though that one of the
functions that newspapers played at
least in the 20th century was a kind of
advice to consumers role where musze
were barely evaluative at all simply
descriptive in which I'm thinking
especially of discourse about film and
other forms of popular culture and I
guess what I'm saying is that it seems
to me that you're that this definition
of criticism as an evaluative process
describes only a portion of what the
popular press in fact would often do
what I mean I'm thinking for example
just of feature stories about actors or
about directors or about new projects
that a a particular theater or dance
group were doing well I'm talking about
we're talking about specifically arts
kritis criticism of the Arts which to me
you know I'm gonna argue pretty strongly
deals for that evaluative judgment there
are other forms of writing about the
art's coverage such as features what I
would call you know puff pieces you know
writing about educational pieces
someone's coming into town we're going
to write about this you know or you know
whatever artistic figure is coming in
and part of what you saw happening in
Doug mentioned 70s and the 80s part of
what happened in the 70s and 80s was an
attempt to sort of meld the two
discourses together there was a time I
don't know if you remember Tina when
Tina Brown was the editor of The New
Yorker she said I don't want reviews I
want what she called future reviews in
other words if you reviewed angels in
america and you read the review about
jaanwar it's a review but that includes
an interview with Tony Kushner it
includes interviews with the people in
the production it was an attempt to say
the review itself the evaluative act is
not as important in and of itself what
we need is that additional material
brought interview material feature
material which is brought in which and
so what you're saying is that those the
line between the feature the reporting
the I was there and I'm going to tell
you what happened has melded thicken
since the 70s the 80s has begun to meld
in but with what you would call the
evaluate a function of arts Chrissy I I
would really strongly disagree with that
Wow mostly because I mean I think the
whole Tina Brown idea of a melding there
that you refer to is is enlarged course
a reaction to what was happening in the
popular press which was which became
more and more thumbs up thumbs down
right it was a pure recommendation we
don't want all that other stuff we want
to be popular we want to have that
consumer reports type of thing and if
you look back at the last 25 years of
criticism in American newspapers the the
preponderance of that the vast majority
of that is that kind of Consumer Reports
type of of writing I would say and I
agree with you that I would just turn
the argue that I'll flip it and simply
say that the Tina Brown approach like
the consumer guide approach essentially
is still about thumbs I mean I did not
read a single Tina Brown feature review
that was a negative review or even very
mixed I mean if I'm lighnator video Tony
Kushner i'm going to review all the
actors and i'm gonna have all what they
say in this review I'm certainly not
going to pan angels in america and
generally jaanwar only and i just want
to talk about john law but other critics
he did that we're inevitably positive in
other words it was thumbs it was just
all the fun was always up and the
attempt was to provide more education
and information in the thumbs up because
there was the fear of I would say the
fair rubber of the reluctance to deal
with the evaluative act which would
challenge the reader to have to deal
with the fact that the critic is raising
interesting provocative points that are
negative or are actually critical of the
art that they're reviewing that's what
everyone is sort of afraid of and that
includes the thumbs up and thumbs down
because there's no evaluation there it's
only I love it I hate it with no
evaluation either whether you why you
like something up or why you like
something down right but I I think that
when you bring up the new yorker which
you know has maybe 34 theater pieces in
a given month
very small number of things that you can
choose over proportionately a tiny
fraction of what you could actually
write about or if your NPR and you have
just a tiny window of it they've made a
decision at some level that okay all
this other stuff that we don't like
we're going to already screen that out
so in a way yes it's it's positive but
it it it becomes positive because
there's a pre-screening that says oh you
know we're not interested in the stuff
we're not interested in and I would just
argue that that we did not have as
strong a pre-screening in like the 19th
century or the turn of the century where
people were excited provoked by reading
reviews that were evaluated that could
be mixed or that could be somewhat
negative I would say the pre-screening
came in with the attempt to create arts
pages and a turn our through doing into
a form of publicity I mean not just
publicity but an attempt to say when you
turn to our arts pages you just want to
read good news maybe you've got a
certain number of leisure dollars you're
going to spend right so you want to
spend your leisure dollars this weekend
and this is why we want you to read our
section because we're just going to have
positive things to say it's all been
pre-screened all the other day all the
bad art or all the art we don't think
you're worth we haven't explained to you
why we think it's not worth covering we
haven't explained to you why we think
that art is not worthy yes just take our
word for it we prescreened it and we're
only going to give you positive you know
reviews of the things that we think it's
worth spending your money on I'm sorry I
don't mean to be come back but I like
but I welcome it no I I think though
they if you're distinguishing your local
paper they reveled in the bad reviews I
mean how many movie reviews and pop
reviews and you know I mean I all kinds
of reviews there there are bad reviews
those never went away but when you're
talking about shall I say sort of
high-end kind of more thoughtful writing
I think that that they did make a
conscious choice to to do that kind of
pre-screening but that that consumer
reports type of thing which is that the
overwhelming majority of what has been
in the arts press for 30 years never
shied away from that
negative condo well I mean I would argue
that when you're talking about like pop
music you're talking about film now
we're talking about again that divide
between popular culture instead of high
culture it's a matter of economics in
that case in other words you covered a
lot of movies because you have the movie
ads that we're coming into your
newspaper or a magazine or TV station so
that meant you know you wanted to cover
it since they're all these big Hollywood
film production companies that are
sending all these let's say mediocre
films out you don't pre-screen those
because they're buying ads in your
newspaper and magazine you want to cover
yeah now I agree because they're mass
art that there's a vastly larger
audience for them and so you're going to
but you could pre-screen them one of the
implications of what you guys are saying
is that not only that there was no
Golden Age but you you sorta you sort of
set the groundwork for the idea that
once we begin to talk about what's
happening on the internet there is no
there can't be a falling off because
you've in a certain sense been so
dubious about about the idealizing
claims for this older form of discourse
but the only thing I would add is that
it's important to recognize that this
it's oversimplified to talk about a
split between our so-called high culture
and popular culture but it's not
oversimplified to talk about a kind of
split in what we might call art arts
criticism that appears in places like
the old defunct partisan review or
commentary or the new york review of
books as against the kind of or the
poetry magazine as against the kind of
writing about arts that we would find in
more popular places even more
generalized popular places such even the
New Yorker which probably occupies a
kind of mid middle position between
those between those and it doesn't seem
to me that the kind of discourse we're
talking about has declined that much in
these in these what I'll call sort of
high culture or literary environments I
mean the you know the the poetry
magazine is still publishing
vituperative reviews by Witt by by
various angry poet critics who are very
hostile to their contemporaries and
there's a great deal you know there's a
great deal of that kind of thing still
going on I mentioned that partly because
I want to introduce a basic principle
that that seems important for us to be
thinking about as we discuss because
we're going to move now to talking about
what's happening on the internet with
arts criticism which is what these what
these folks really have something is
important to tell us about I think let's
remember that if there is a kind of
revolution in quotation marks going on
it's a very very long revolution it's
it's really that there clearly is happeh
the way it is clearly the case that
virtually all the elements of what we
might associate with the with with print
culture is migrating into digital form
but that process is going to take
decades if not centuries it's not going
to happen overnight there isn't going to
be a sudden moment where we wake up in
the morning and there are no there's no
longer any print discourse and all of
the discourse is taking place on the web
there there's and there is also as our
speakers I'm sure we'll be able to
illustrate for us some kind of overlap
between what goes on in print culture
and what goes on in there in the on the
internet so that so the perspective I
want to suggest is a perspective of
continuity let us say let's accept that
big things are happening but let's also
recognize that they're not happening in
a kind of revolutionary way so that so
that the old is suddenly completely
obliterated by my new developments quite
the opposite the new imitates the old
takes its forms from the old extends
itself by modeling itself on its
ancestors as it before it begins to
discover what is unique or special about
the new media that are emerging in our
own time and if we keep that continuity
principle in in perspective in our in
our minds it can help put many of the
arguments that we'll be hearing this
afternoon in context well let's let's
turn it we've talked to bit then about
some of the powerful limitations that
existed even before the internet on
forms of popular or generalized art
critic arts criticism let's turn now to
more specifically what's happening to
all these traditional formats for arts
arts discourse because of the internet
how is the internet changing things what
are some of the decisive points that you
guys would point to to illustrate the
ways in
which it the emerging digital culture
where this impending future that we're
all moving into whether we want to or
not how is how is our its criticism
altering and changing so I want to build
on a couple of things that you've just
said one is this that there are that
there are things that the traditional
press never did very well in terms of
covering culture never covered dance
very well never covered Community Arts
very well I mean there's a whole range
of kinds of culture that the traditional
press never found a way to either
capture pay attention to or translate in
a kind of interesting way and what we're
finding now there are you know 300,000
arts blogs out there right now 300,000
people who feel like they have something
to say it's not to say that they all do
really in fact have something to say but
that there is there is a desire out
there to engage in the kind of
conversation the second thing I wanted
to bring up is that you said that is
sort of a gradual thing over a long
period I actually would disagree with
that I seem to be the the panel disagree
or here today I think that they were
undergoing a revolution in the larger
culture right now i mean i think that
the ways that people are using culture
the ways that people are making culture
the expectations for how they get it how
they use it and how they want to
participate it are really radically
changing we're going from an era where
it's been essentially a broadcast model
where whether i'm a theater or i'm a
musician or I'm a journalist I have
something to make you the audience come
and see it and then I say goodbye to you
and you go off and you do your thing now
it's it's a much more interactive kind
of thing and because people have access
suddenly to the entire world it seems
and there are you know thousands and
thousands of choices for how you want to
spend your time or what gets your
attention that that that conversation is
is basically changing and what the what
the studies in
cultural choice tell us right now from
from the curb center at Vanderbilt and
USC's center for the the digital future
is that younger people particularly are
not going online to find information
anymore they're going online to have
community they're going online to be
interactive and to have interactive
experience so they tend to that the
studies also say is that they tend to
trust less those kinds of media that
they that they have interaction with
that have closed editorial systems so in
other words we distrust they distrust
things which are the expert kind of
analysis that I'm just telling you this
and you do with it what you want they
tend to trust more things in which they
can participate in the editorial
experience and it's not just to talk
about things either it's up in creating
things a recent Pew studies is that
something like eighty nine percent of
everybody under the age of 25 makes art
on the Internet in some way they do want
to have that interactive experience so
if the culture is changing radically
like that I believe and we're going back
actually not to something that that has
never happened before I think this is a
continual kind of reinvention that
happens every time you technologies
happen and we've undergone it many many
times before in history but it is still
fundamentally different that if that
culture is changing and how people are
going to approach culture and interact
with culture is changing then the
journalism around it necessarily has to
change in pretty significant ways and
that means not having that kind of
expert from afar kind of Association
people want to have people like
expertise still but they also want to
have some sort of interaction with it
well let me build on a couple points 1
point that David meet I mean I do think
we're in
in a page of transition and Doug was
talking about you know everyone is
making art and the interest in art i
would say we're also at we're in age a
transition of how we articulate our
reactions to and evaluate what art means
to us and in that way I'm with David in
the sense that I think that their needs
in this transition there needs to be
some taken from the old and brought into
the new because as I mentioned before if
I think criticism and i believe it is it
is evaluate it is judgment with
evaluation then the biggest thing I see
missing in a lot of going on in writing
about the arts is the evaluative act we
have people describing liat people
reporting we have people emoting you
know we have people opinionated they
have opinions but they have no ability
apparently to articulate to react to the
art in a way which can communicate to
others in a reasonable way why the art
made them feel the way they feel why
they value the art now to me and this is
one thing we missed and talking about
the value of arts criticism part of what
arts criticism has always been about at
least ideally I you know I agree that
it's there it's been a lot of potholes
along the way of history is that we
articulate the importance of the Arts to
us the value they give us a value they
give our lives in order right to
communicate that importance that value
to the culture in the society at large
in other words you need you can see a
great performance you need to be able to
articulate about how you came to your
conclusion about why that performance
was so great to others to share through
others and also simply to make that
become you know part of the culture it's
about articulating so what we need that
the articulation aspect is what we need
to sort of transition from the past when
there were expectations under sort of
editorial guidance that when you opened
a review you would reader ideally you
really review that not only gave you a
judgment but also gave you also
evaluated that seems to be slipping to
me in what's going on in what we're
talking about in the in the three
million blogs or three thousand hundred
blogs that we have writing about the
arts people who are reacting to the arts
people who are making the arts but are
unable apparently because I really don't
have an idea of what reviewing criticism
or articulating value is to be able to
put that into some
sort of language so I'd say that's part
of it but the part I gave with with doug
is that it is say the interactive part I
find the most exciting part of what's
happening now because through the
interaction it seems to me that is where
those who can articulate right can can
train educate learn from those who need
or struggling to or who want to
articulate what the arts mean to them
you know and that then becomes part of
on that becomes part of the internet
culture also becomes part of the society
and the general culture so it's that
connection that I see the interaction
can bring between those who can
articulate and those who want I me
because I see a great need in a way I
mean a lot of when I teach at BU I have
a lot of students who they have
reactions they have opinions and they
actually become interested in the idea
they realize that they have an opinion
and then they begin to realize that they
have to learn ways in which you are
picked articulate that opinion to give
some of the listener or ever the reasons
behind that opinion in order to share
their insight to make that valid make
that clear to the person who's who's
listening so to me the interaction
brings about the connection between the
professionals and the non-professionals
hopefully in a place where both will
feel free to be able to exchange
opinions and views and learn from one
another so to me the top down I'll just
went quickly i mean i think the blog is
an interesting form but i must admit
when I look at a lot of blogs and i'm
not saying globalize a lot of odds are
still they get comments the comments sit
there right the comments are sort of
badges of honor gee I said something and
I got a lot of comments where's the
community the critic doesn't talk to the
people who are commenting the critic
doesn't try to make them part of the
blog by saying hey come on and explain
more about what you say about this art
of that art essentially it's just
numbers right I wrote a blog in which I
got so many reactions and what really
needs to be done the next step is
probably going to be finding ways to be
able to bring the blog or together with
the people who are really interested
they're responding right and use that
space to be able to create the talk
about you know to create the means of
articulation and training of both that
need to
be done so I don't see enough
interaction in criticism complicate this
argument about interaction a little bit
because as you were talking I was
thinking of what I would think of a sort
of more traditional forms of activity on
it but on the internet that also involve
a mod acum of interactivity not the same
kind of interactivity that would be
involved in the notion that someone
would put up a piece of prose fiction
and invite his his or her readers to
write a chapter to me a very dubious
kind of interactivity actually but I can
I can certainly have seen text that that
have emerged like that but a more modest
kind of interactivity of the sort that
occurs all over the place on the
internet maybe even larger in terms of
numbers than what you get from blogs I'm
thinking about the way in which
traditional media like the New York
Times have a presence on the web and
after virtually every article not just
their articles on the arts there's a
reader's forum and there are elaborate
commentaries and disco discourse amongst
the REE that's a form of interactivity
that that grows out of a very
traditional kind of media arrangement
but the times realizes now that there
it's online it has this new option I I
think we ought not to be too quick to to
denigrate or ignore these more modest
forms of interactivity because I think
they're quite exciting that what they do
in effect is they invite the readers of
the commentary to react and to disagree
or to enlarge or to wart or to carry the
argument in different directions and I
mentioned the times because of course
it's a very important web presence
already but it represents this
continuity principle to me and I think
it's I think that there are many other
examples of this sort of thing on the on
the web one other example I want to
mention that I find actually very
inspiring because of course one might
think of poetry is the oldest art since
it began before print before spare
before language before writing actually
people were reciting poetry in the in
the era before the alphabet and yet one
might make an argument for the idea that
the net is reinvigorating certain for
certain acts access to poetry in ways
that have never been possible before a
kind of marriage of
the old and new that I find very
inspiring and my example is the
wonderful monthly discussion on Slate
run by the former poet laureate Robert
Pinsky every every month in every week
in Slate Pinsky as the poetry editor
publishes a poem but by a contemporary
poet and in three of the four weeks it's
just that poem and readers are
encouraged to comment on it but on in
the fourth week and and in fact every
poem that's published in slate is then
followed by a very elaborate sort of
discourse about the poem by a by a
community of poetry lovers but every
every fourth week Pinsky publishes a
poem from the past that's out of
copyright poems by Sir Walter Raleigh by
Shakespeare by Sir Thomas Wyatt but by
lesser-known poets as well writes a
brief introduction and then encourages
people to discuss the poem those are
among the most interesting forms of
discourse about poetry that I think I've
ever read and one of the reasons for it
is a an astonishing number of practicing
poets take plot take part in those
discussions this is simply one example
and I are those of you don't know about
this even if you have only a model of
interest in poetry you might take a look
at these at these monthly sessions
they're all they're all archived on the
slate site because they they seem to me
to represent an immense enlargement of
what we might think of as traditional
forms of discourse about poetry again a
kind of partly a continuity or argument
so so so I would again qualify what you
guys are saying even though I don't
actually in any way disagree with with
the basic thrust of your argument see I
I think human nature doesn't change I
think the reason that we have you know
the reason we have all of these all of
this vocabulary that tells us you know
in media this story is more important
than that story pay attention to this
pay attention to that you know
something's on a one in an important
newspaper we know it means something if
it's on page 22 and you know we know it
means something else we have that in
spades on on the internet there are all
sorts of ways it
it's a different kind of vocabulary but
it's a very strongly articulated cat
vocabulary and it's one which you
actually have to take an awful lot of
labor to learn you can't just make the
switch overnight so that's that's part 1
part 2 is that I think that the values
of traditional journalism of traditional
arts journalism and criticism and all of
that we have developed them over an
awfully long time they don't suddenly
just disappear because we have you know
we have a shiny new tool to play and
they want them to do that's right and
and and they will be real articulated
and reimagined in in some very
interesting ways but I think that those
values will continue to reassert
themselves as we go along I mean I I
agree I guess I'm just a you know maybe
I'm more impatient to the extent that
you know I see generation you know a
generation of students now that they
really don't know what a review is in
other words if you're not given that
sort of exposure to a review in other
words you don't you know the typical
newspaper review or whatever and you
would get it your hometown paper at
least know what a review was if you see
what passes for reviews on youtube or a
number of other you know a three-minute
video video sometimes you know videotape
rat then the idea is that you they don't
know that it's what that reasoning
evaluation with reasoning means they
really don't other words i do think i'm
not i am optimistic ultimately but i
think the struggle so i guess your
transition i think i'm a bit of a bit of
a revolutionary in that way i do think
that these values that you're talking
about or not just going to sort of
naturally sort of pop up i think you
know people who work on the web and
write about the arts on the web have to
actively put you know make put those
values forward to make sure that they're
not contributing to two people who
really no longer know what it review is
the definition of review becomes like
what they saw in Siskel and Ebert I mean
that essentially is what really it's
what for a lot of younger people that's
what a review is you you have a movie
clip and you say whether you like it or
you don't like it and then you have
another movie
and you say thumbs up or thumbs down
they see it purely as a consumer guide
sort of option and not about as
evaluated reasoning and so and if they
if they're not exposed to it if they're
not talk to you about it if they're not
shown what a review can do and the power
of it and how it can be illuminating
then you know I mean I'm with you but
I'm just saying that I'm we need more
people to assert those values to make
sure that that the generations can
continue that transition what you say
makes sense bill and I'm sure you're
right about that well as you were
talking I was thinking for example about
the week but let's call them reviews in
quotes that you see on amazon right the
fact of the matter is if you read
through the responses to particular text
on Amazon it's very easy about no reader
could possibly fail to recognize which
responses are actually really
substantial respond to the content of
the text in a way that you find
persuasive and as against those that are
just puff pieces or so totally
subjective that they're useless to
someone else and I think that some of
that is good so there's some element of
kind of self-education happens because
as people have get more and more
practice with blogs and with responses
of the sort you find on on Amazon after
particular comments on particular books
on Amazon you be and so many other
places on the web where things like that
occur you begin to develop your own sort
of critical standards because you're
forced to you you know that you can't
you can't believe everything that you're
in some of what you read seems so silly
that you immediately dismiss it so while
i agree billet and i would like all
students to study either in my class or
in those class so we could teach them
how there are actually some objective
standards that one could use to begin to
talk about what constitutes an effective
effective more powerful forms of art i
think it's also possible that people
begin to sort of educate themselves
through a process like that what I will
say that just about Amazon just because
we haven't even talked about or we
touched on the issue of independence or
ethics and that's I know a number of
highly articulate people who have
written reviews of books that are
competing with their book and they have
put it under another name
and they have deep sixed very
articulately very thoughtfully the book
that is that essentially maybe taking
some of the market share away from their
book so I agree but I want to say that
without as we are back imposed Wild West
days here and you cannot necessarily as
articulate as a review maybe it can also
be compromised corrupt and this is and
the web is one way in which you can use
perhaps a modicum of intelligence to
look you know to make your point in it
in a very let's say underhanded or
devious way and so that's if that's the
problem without any sort of editorial
control both of you guys feel that that
the opportunity for this kind of abuse
is more common on the web than earlier
and one reason I mention that is to
reinforce something bill said at the
very beginning we tend to idealize the
past but the fact of the matter is that
the more we learn about the history of
the reception of literature the more we
discovered that this kind of corruption
was endemic many of you may not know
this it's sort of an embarrassment to
people who love James Joyce but James
Joyce interfered with and took and the
reception of his books in all kinds of
ways he actually wrote reviews of his
books under other names he he had books
published under the names of friends of
his that mostly were his work he tried
he tried his best this great know this
the pivotal figure of modernism no doubt
a very great writer was very concerned
with his reputation and had no
conscience at all about trying to sort
of enhance his reputation in in various
in various published forms and of course
this is not a unique situation at all
where there are there are hundreds of
stories about this some of them about
our most admired and respected writers
and artists from the past quick one only
that you know I'm a big fan of Edgar
Allan Poe I think it was one of the
great the greatest American critic of
the 19th century but he routinely
reviewed his own works anonymously in
fact Poe being Poe he once reviewed one
of his own works anonymously impounded
he also did a wonderful review of
Nathaniel Hawthorne in which he in which
after saying how great
Thorne was he that had a chunk of a
short story saying I think Hawthorne for
all of his greatness plagiarized from
this story in order to make some of his
story so good and of course the story
that he said Nathaniel Hawthorne a play
droids from was by Edgar Allan Poe
William Wilson so I don't really think
in terms of just the the Wild West
ethics of it I think that online is not
all that different than what Poe had to
deal with in them in the in the 1830s
1840s where reviews were anonymous where
in fact I think it's actually a little
better because I haven't heard of anyone
getting killed over review I've heard of
any jewels routinely imposed day if you
wrote something very by to prohibit
personal and they did all the time
including PO someone would you know the
fellow critic would find you in a you
know having a drink somewhere invite you
out and people are either a brought into
court or they were killed and some
critics did end up bloody bruised and
even dead if once I found out
anonymously you see they would find out
through the editor who really wrote this
review and pan my book and they they go
out and draw blood so I think we're a
little better than that I haven't heard
of any less Doug sort of any death
through criticism online no but I do
think that one one problem right now and
it is a wild west out there is that
whereas you know in the last 50 years
let's say there were some pretty bright
lines that were drawn about you know
what is ethical and what is it not
ethical which is not to say that that
people didn't cross back and forth
across them all the time but there was
at least a sort of understanding that
there is this kind of ethical you know
divide here I think that a lot of people
writing now they don't even have they're
not even aware when something is
unethical you know somebody pimping for
their own thing somebody you know
pushing a friend's book I think there
are a lot of people who are writing and
think they're they're being completely
ethical and and they have no idea so in
in in one way is we even if nobody even
if a lot of people or a lot of
publications didn't follow the ethical
rules of the past there were at least
ethical rules of the past and I'm not so
sure that those have been articulated in
in any kind of compelling way that's
been widespread adopted our conversation
we open it to the audience let me ask
you to be each of you to be more a
little bit more specific pink pick some
element of Arts criticism on the web or
a site on the web but you think
illustrates positive and hopeful
directions and in this you go first what
we recently I recently helped organize a
thing at USC as a summit on on arts
journalism state of arts journalism and
one of the things that we tried to do
was to find anybody it came out of this
idea that that we saw hundreds of new
sites launching and a lot of people
trying to solve various problems and so
you know would it be great to get ten
ideas out on the table and let's let's
take a look at we opened it up people
could nominate sites and we got 109
nominations of sites to participate in
this what was interesting for me was
that there was no site out there that
really had figured out a model a thing
that that is particularly working right
now some of them had something very
interesting going in some way there's a
site by the by the name of flip media FL
YP that's trying to reinvent the
magazine for the digital world and it's
it's using all sorts of very interesting
design and graphic and interactive
things for but there are problems with
content and you know it's it's not fully
realized yet there's a project called
departures KCET that the public
television station in Los Angeles where
they'll go to a neighborhood and they'll
put people they'll try and capture the
culprit culture of that neighborhood by
doing a whole series of interviews and
embedding them in a collage of
images of the street and by the way that
they choose them and by the way that
they ordered them you get a pretty good
sense or you get a sense of what's
happening on the street but there's a
critical element missing there are sites
that are doing that that are doing
criticism pure criticism essentially
transferred from the traditional print
model to to online and they seem to be
doing pretty well a glass tire in tech
does Texas art San Francisco classical
vice does classical music in the Bay
Area and in some of these places there
are cities now like San Francisco where
classical music is better covered now
than it ever has been before because you
have these sites that are going I
they've developed a whole cadre of you
know 4050 people who will go out and
review and and actually know something
about what it is that they're talking
about and and do it in kind of an
interesting way in a comprehensive way
which the local newspapers have never
ever before been able to do so here
there you see sort of glimmers of things
going on the thing the things to me that
aren't happening one is nobody has
figured out a business model yeah I mean
at heart here what we're talking about
is a failure of a journalistic model to
support arts journalism to support any
journalism frankly but to poor
specifically support arts journalism and
while you have some sort of struggling
models out there nobody has really kind
of figured out a way that that is is is
going to propel it forward in a in a way
that can be replicable in a lot of
communities the other thing is is that
with all of the technical facility and
the various media that we have available
now for the most part most of the stuff
that's happening out there continues to
be some sort of reinvention of something
we're already doing in other words that
there is this idea out there that the
500 word critical response text response
to a piece of art is somehow the
perfection of the critical response and
I would suggest that the you know if
you're describing dance every time you
try to describe what's happening or to
make judgments about it it's a
compromise to translate it into verbal
language maybe there are better ways in
different media to be able to capture or
to react to make that credit critical
response there isn't nearly enough going
on I mean I can point to lots of
examples of little things but nothing
that sort of you sort of go oh that's
such a better way of trying to to
respond to a piece of art what is it
that such an important point it seems to
me is that there are certain forms of
criticism dance criticism is a wonderful
example but so is film criticism
theoretically the web enables forms of
dance and film criticism even if drama
criticism if you could film the
performance that allows you not to fall
back simply on words but to actually
look at the physical movements of the
performer and draw conclusions on the
basis of that or just call attention to
certainly and the web of enables let's
say a form of film criticism or a form
of dance criticism that never existed in
print media earlier and are you're
suggesting that in fact that hasn't been
exploited as richly as a champion music
for instance but maybe if you're trying
to describe the texture of a sound maybe
a visual image describes it in a better
way then then maybe just anything right
you're also i just i mean the sex
excites me only because i really like I
completely concur I mean it seems to me
that that's why I'm optimistic
optimistic and excited about arts
criticism because it seems to me that if
you use the technology if you use the
multimedia if you experiment with what
articulating your response to the arts
means then it seems to me that's going
to be important part of the future and
for some reason and I don't know why and
it's awfully frustrating we don't see
enough attempts to use for example in
dance actually to use video to interpret
that with whatever you know with a
podcast/videocast whatever you want to
do t
intricate actually seeing something and
then evaluating it describing it and you
know and illuminating it hopefully
forever whose forever whose wife forever
who's watching so I agree that entirely
that that for some reason I don't know
why that that challenge and it is a
challenge and that's another thing wide
sort of revolutionary mean that's a
challenge that should be taken up by
people who are interested in arts
criticism when I teach it be you they
say for example the Graduate that comm
dept it be you or you know journalism J
school when they when people write on
their applications for graduate school
what kind of thing do they want to do in
journalism the majority of them want to
cover the arts they want to cover the
arts they want to write about the arts
because it interests them so it seems to
me that's where the energy the ideas are
probably going to have to come from from
people who are familiar with the
technology and can literally reinvent
the form of the Arts Review as long as
you keep at least one eye on that idea
of the past and the idea that one has to
articulate some sort of evaluative you
know you have to have reasons to behind
your judgment but I think you can easily
marry that with the things that you're
both talking about in terms of
articulating how you respond to work of
art let's conclude our part of the
conversation get your questions and
arguments ready audience with a with my
asking each of you briefly to talk about
the sites you're responsible for and
what you're what you're up to with your
sites are lying here's my you know I get
my commercial get in here I mine i dint
the arts use which is it a as you can
see the site up there and it's
essentially a dedicated to covering Arts
in New England it focuses on critical
responses although not only on those the
thing I want to highlight now is as you
can see judicial theater review number
one this is my attempt again to
experiment not so much with technology
but to experiment the idea of creating a
sense of dialogue and civic community
online so what I've done is I've taken
the US Supreme Court is a model and
essentially what i do is that i send out
a number of judges to in this case it
was to a theater piece one of them is a
prevent you know not all them are
professional critics some of them is is
specialized in the subject matter that
the play was about they came back with
their judgments i edited them I
posted them I then give you away if I
can scare you to see this or nothing oh
I gotta hang on for a sec up so I edited
them so I have a little preference
explaining what this is there's a
majority opinion a dissenting opinion
that I have the different judges there
are their judgments then I have the the
artistic organization then has a
friend-of-the-court brief so the idea is
to create a community where you can have
three different points of view because
all the judges were somewhat different
in how they saw the show and they coming
up from different points of view and
you're including the response of the
artistic you know in this case the
theatre company that was involved in a
place where because not all the judges
love this show they actually were
somewhat missed about it they mixed
about it they thought it was an
important play about important subject
new sketch Rwanda and genocide in Rwanda
but it the you know the characters and
the plot had problems yet the
artistically the community the the
artistic institution in this case
company one felt comfortable enough
about posting and responding this is to
me my attempt to try to create a
community because I want people who
respond and I invite anyone hear pleas
to read and respond to become part of
this community talking about display and
maybe eventually at some point becoming
a judge you know in other words getting
on a panel and a panel also can be taken
from local communities so I could have
judges or panelists coming from all over
the state that could become part of you
know covering this particular event for
their community so it's an attempt to
create this sort of communal space that
will bring together professionals people
who articulate about the arts sort of
for a living or used to and then those
people who are interested in
articulating their responses of the art
in a place where everyone can feel
because it is there is an edited quality
to it meaning I am editing the material
I don't want comments on there that are
that are demeaning or stupid or
insulting I'm not interested in snark
what I'm interested in is actually
seriously talking about in this case
this play and hopefully involving a
community
people who can trade ideas and views on
it so this is this is what I edit and
this is my latest idea to try to
reinvent the art form by combining the
professional that with the
non-professional and trying to create a
community around that so that that is
the art skills Oh
I edit something called arts journal com
we just had our 10th anniversary we
started in September of 1999 and what
arts journal was an attempt to do I
actually came up with it when i was
browsing the philadelphia inquirer site
one time one day and discovered a story
about the Barnes collection being in
difficulty and realized that it was
couple they don't need me to put our
Tito lead to say to those that it was in
trouble but it was a couple of weeks old
and so I thought they're probably
stories like this all over the place and
if I could just put them together I
could have my own arts section that was
on a Tuesday on a wednesday i registered
the name had bought some some books on
HTML and spent the weekend kind of
putting it up and it launched on the
monday and it's been going for 10 years
we have bloggers on the site we have 60
for bloggers currently most of them are
ex newspaper people or still newspaper
people all with kinds of various kinds
of followings across all of the arts
what our external does sort its main
function is we look at about 200
publications worldwide anything in
English everyday about 1500 to 2000
stories every day and then we boil it
down to the 20 to 30 that we think are
interesting and that you ought to know
about and then we have all of these
other blogs we also curate discussions
so we'll invite the 12 people you'd like
to hear on a topic and they'll blog
about it for a week and God we're in the
midst of completely reinventing the site
I I don't think that what arts journal
is right now is going to be viable going
forward we have about fifty to sixty
thousand people a day that use the site
I found two years ago when I redesigned
it the last time I was kind of surprised
to discover that
only about twenty-five percent of people
actually use it ever come to the website
in fact the vast majority of people
don't even know it's a website they were
getting it in newsletters we've got
35,000 newsletter subscribers or in
feeds or their accounting it in other
sites or etc etc etc I think that the
challenge in journalism right now is we
have too much information out there
although somebody told me recently it's
like there's not more information now
than there ever has been it's just our
access is to it is is more comprehensive
so the challenge now is not to create so
much more information it's to find ways
to make the information that we have
coherent and put it together in some
interesting ways so that the new version
of arts journal I'm moving towards is
more community-based where you'll be
able to curate what it is that you want
to see in various levels so you can get
the very highly curated thing that we do
now but then there will be different
levels of curation with the involvement
in interaction of the community which is
actually very smart yeah so actually
makes money yeah this seems an important
point we launched in September of 1999
at the height of the dot-com bubble a
month later the New York Times wrote
about us that that helped in about a
week later somebody called a company
called up and says we can make you a
millionaire for Christmas you take that
call and immediately we started making
money telling the truth yeah they work
there so nor a millionaire no because I
didn't sell it ah they that was the day
those were the days in web one point 0
where you know content is king so
everybody was desperate for content so
we could sell feeds of our content to
all sorts of clients and so we grew
rather rather large in a six week period
in april of 2000 all of a sudden every
one of our clients went out of business
including the people who had had offered
the million dollars for the site
so as good thing we didn't take it right
because all of those you know wild ideas
they really didn't pan out and what I've
learned over time in doing our external
is that you can't you know I thought it
would be I would find a source of
revenue for the site and that would be
it that has not proved to be true we
sell subscriptions people people by
subscriptions to the newsletter premium
newsletter we have advertising we have
all we supplied news to other sites with
their a variety of ways and there are
times when one mode is generating most
of our revenue and the others are not
but it changes over time and you have to
be nimble enough to be able to go for
the mix now we turn to the audience and
I urge you what when you there are Mike
there's a microphone here is there
another one on this side only one says
there's a microphone on either side if
you line up in front of the mics I will
call on you in order identify yourselves
before you speak so you can become part
of the permanent record of the event is
that on is that microphone on I don't
hear it okay it is okay I'll lean closer
and i was first off i'm really glad that
you're here because you have a
perspective that i don't often see on
the internet in fact to the point where
i was wondering do we share the same
internet like do we you know and i'm
beginning to think that maybe this is a
sign of just a complete worldview
difference probably because of our
generations i guess the thing that i've
been wondering is you continue talking
about this apart from occasionally
wanting you to give examples such as
blogs where the comments don't like lead
to greater things because i feel like i
go to many blogs where the comments get
involved but but I start thinking you
know you guys are very into this thing
of expertise your variant expertise
you're into someone curating for you is
what I'm getting you're into the idea
there are people who are experts who
there have been like and created experts
by a journalism school or wherever which
I think that there is value to this by
the way
many of my friends are journalists but
he rented this idea of these people that
we are going to return to their place
sort of right like the web has
destabilized this journalism thing and
somehow those of us who aren't experts
are going to want to return the experts
to their place are going to want to like
listen to the reviews of someone who has
gone to journalism school it has their
own their own background their own
opinion you know and has heretofore been
sort of on a broadcast model been
telling us what they think without real
you know with with the major soapbox
they've got the big soapbox I'm having a
hard time understanding why I would want
to do that why wouldn't I want to
continue to educate myself as much as I
can and and form my own opinions and get
into conversations and not look to one
major you know reviewer or one central
place or even a small panel of people
even even a three-person panel who may
or may not share my own you know sort of
goals as to what i should be listening
to and i understand that you guys are a
small subset of what you would dream
arts reviewers to be but it still says
seem to vary it does not seemed very uh
internet like to me what you guys have
been talking about well I to me I don't
quite see if you're going to you want to
go in and you want to educate yourself
then you're going to go to as many
different sources and you're going to
educate yourself in many different ways
as you can so this panel of three might
be one way arts journal might be another
in other words you're going to try to
absorb and use and ultimately filter
unless you want to just continually go
and go through hundreds of blogs every
day or every week so that you're part of
your education process is that you are
going to becoming educated about those
people whose ideas opinions matter to
you and perhaps then you will write to
them and then you'll you'll create that
relationship so I don't see the you know
I mean how are you going to educate
yourself you're going to be learning
actively by going on the web taking what
you need and discarding what you don't
need yeah I actually agree with you I I
don't see that there's going to ever be
a return to the expert
I wouldn't tote that as a model that we
should you know want to go for I think
that that you know the niche ification
of culture that's happened means that
that kind of broadly based mass culture
in which you know the mushy middle rules
because it can you know it can aggregate
the most eyeballs is not a model that is
ultimately going to be able to sustain
itself and we're seeing all of those
kinds of mass culture lose audience
share you know forty fifty sixty percent
I mean all of those business models are
failing that said I mean I spend some of
the most interesting people i'm reading
these days are not journalists they're
people who are doing the things that
they love and are studying it and and
have a way of expressing their point of
view about it in a way they are experts
in their thing and you value those with
with you know very much and so I think
that the challenge is really to find
curators that you grow to trust people
who can filter for you and yeah I just
as you've been speaking I realized that
my main response i think was because you
guys were talking about oh the many
bloggers who are doing it wrong and the
many YouTube commentators who are doing
it wrong and my perspective is hey those
are probably you know young people who
are trying to learn to do it right
what's wrong with them doing here and
there are so many amazing blogs and
things that that you know yeah I mean
lots of blogs are doing it by I mean I'm
excited by the activity that I see going
on and look I don't know I didn't want
to say they're doing it wrong I think
they're they are on the process of
getting hopefully better and better and
better I just think that if you see it
sort of siskel ebert like review on
YouTube I'm hoping eventually that this
critic will grow out of that model and
will be able to write you know be able
to write or deal with them in with film
art in a far more sophisticated way you
know more complex way that's all but I
think for every one of those there there
is somebody who's doing in there looks
right yes of course you know this whole
is this whole sort of movement right now
doing response videos to things that you
see online yeah
are just amazingly done well done yeah
we obviously need to say more and I hope
panelists and the audience will talk
more about this broad question clearly
there is a kind of profoundly
democratizing tendency built into these
new technologies and there are both
positive and negative implications of
them the positive implications may not
have been stressed enough but i do want
briefly to respond to flourish clinks
comments by reminding her that there's
that she's a very active blogger and in
fact and in fact especially active in in
certain in certain territories on the
web and she's listened to more than
others are why not because someone
designated her as an expert maybe we
need this distinction but because
there's a difference between what we
might call authority and expertise you
get authority not because someone grants
it to you but because you write well and
people start paying attention to you
that's why people read flourish on harry
potter more than the other harry potter
of bloggers who come and and that's and
that's and that's all that that's why
presumably hopefully particular
particular participants in these in
these endless forums will be generate
more views and more and more and more
responses than others do if that's what
happen if that is going to happen or or
or what if that is a prime tendency on
the web as I hope and believe it is or
will be I think that's a very healthy
sign it means that not that there won't
be people whose whose opinions or whose
perspectives are not more valued than
others but they'll be valued because the
authority they've generated has been
granted to them by a kind of response by
all of all of the readers all of the
users that's all that was part of the
traditional idea of journalists in other
words when journalists began writing
reviews you know they might have been
gotten the job but if they became
popular admired whatever they they had
to fight um hi I'm Nick Seaver I'm a
master's student and compared to media
studies also and I have a similar
question on a similar idea but not so
much about who was doing the criticism
but how you talked a lot about how
people aren't doing enough of
you would have work or judgmental work
and they're mostly just like summarizing
what happens in sort of puff pieces and
I'm curious if you could get more
specific about how you see the
evaluative function changing as
criticism moves on line moves in these
various ways of different people because
you talked expertly about the history of
how arts journalism evolved over time
but there was the sort of implicit
assumption that the role of the
evaluator was somehow static in here
like the proper way of evaluating has
been the same and they used to be bad at
it and they got good at it and they were
bad at it and then they were good at it
again but I'm curious whether you see
that role that evaluative function
changing at all like with the times
because I would imagine arts journalists
from 1900 have would have weird things
to say about arts from you know 2009 are
you dressed or anyone is to anyone all
right i mean i'll take it and just um I
mean I wish I did I mean I think you
that's a really pivotal issue for me and
in a way I don't have an easy answer I
mean that's sort of to me that's what's
being discovered right now in other
words if we take the idea of what
evaluative reasoning was in the 19th
century the 20th century if you go back
and I would suggest if you are writing
arts journalism or think about writing
dark arts journalism online read some of
the great critics of the past you don't
have to imitate them but they are they
perhaps we'll give you the tools and the
values to begin to think what can i
bring from the past to what's going on
online now what do I now have to do
different knew that wasn't done in the
past so we already talked about various
uses of multimedia perhaps you could do
a dance piece where you don't
necessarily writing a 500 600 word
evaluation but you're using video you
know maybe reviews are going to go more
towards a form of podcasting or
videocast and you perhaps we'll be
working with ways in which one can place
more evaluative material in it either
using visuals or using language but to
me that that to me is a fascinating
challenge of what's happening today what
is it and if we assume that evaluation
is pivotal in what makes a review then
what can we what can we transition from
the past that will fit online you know
with what a lot of people feel are you
know arrest
attention spans and people who don't
want to read long magazine like pieces
what forms evaluation can we bring that
go beyond the sort of thumbs up and
thumbs down or simply giving an opinion
so I don't have an easy i think i think
this is what we're working on right now
it's what people are going to be and
unfortunately we haven't seen enough
experimentation on that end terms of how
can we take evaluative discourse
traditional discourse and place it
online what works what doesn't work what
pleases readers and what maybe doesn't
please readers but that you want to do
anyway because it's challenging because
you are concerned with the crap the
criticism itself and you want to see
what values you can bring from the past
and bring it in into today and see what
works and what doesn't work thank you hi
my name is Dinah Carden and I actually
in one of the three hundred thousand art
blog people you talked about although we
don't like to think of it as a blog it's
an online arts magazine for the North
Shore called art throb based in Salem
and I teach at salem state college and i
have interns there who were involved and
dog i was one of the 109 people to
participate in your online arts model in
california and i thought that was a
great project sitting here today so many
things that you've said or I'm nodding
along if someone's mentioned a cadre of
writers that's what we call our writers
is our cadre and with dance we've had a
writer who is a dance or writing about
dance talking about how hard it is to
write about dance and the idea of video
is actually really good my background is
in journalism from Boston University but
I I wouldn't want to see the written
word go away because that is my
background I've been an arts writer on
the North Shore and also worked as a
staff writer in straight news but the
thought of it really scares me to
imagine that you would go online and
just see videos of people doing things
because the last thing we need is for
young people to literally live online
and not go out and see for themselves
what's actually out there and one of the
things that we're doing is building
community
with this publication and you know we're
already hearing we're only six months
old that people are looking to us more
than the mainstream publications for
arts writing but I just would like to
hear you talk about that about we do a
mixture of magazine pieces and also the
brief 500 word post and we're trying to
be very multimedia i dream of npr-style
audio interviews and we do to video and
and other things but I just from it
coming from the the background of the
written word i do want to continue to do
that I'd like to hear you talk about
that there's a recent book out I can't
remember the name of it at the moment
but making the case that we haven't
become less literate in the age of
texting it's actually made us more
literate we're now more literate now
that we've ever been before because if
you go back 20 years ago once people got
out of school they never wrote anything
again now you've got this proliferation
of people writing even if they're small
texts and it has its own kind of form I
think in an odd way that all of this
really short hid stuff in some ways
values the larger pieces it kind of
researched them their purpose you know
when there was a forest of those kinds
of pieces probably not everything needed
to be that long and probably a lot of it
was self-indulgent and probably you know
etc etc if the if the standard moves to
something else there is you know when
somebody attempts the longer form i
think that there's a more appreciative
audience for it so I by no means am I
you know saying hey we should we should
get rid of text reviews or that the text
is not still the primary form of
critical response to something all I'm
suggesting is that that
with all of the options available right
now I don't see an awful lot of
experimentation you know when people
attempt something it's usually based on
that kind of traditional model and they
try and shoehorn it into whatever it is
but you know at for instance i recently
saw a review of a graphical novel
graphical novels are really big right
now in the form of a graphical you know
in the form of a graphical novel you
know pals this is kind of interesting
you know music in response to music
movement in response to movement you
know some of that so ephemeral you know
what is it actually commenting on on the
other hand you know seeing some of these
response videos to some somebody dancing
or somebody doing something on the web
is pretty interesting because it's got a
lot of commentary on what the original
thing was and it died sex it in some
pretty interesting ways so I yeah I
wouldn't say we want to get rid of text
at all I just think though that that we
have to be really clear about how it is
that we use a text perhaps we should
note parenthetically and see again the
the utopian or dystopian discourses that
surround new technologies always distort
a more complicated reality anyhow but
one of the radical oversimplifications
has to do with the death of language
clearly languages migratory across
platforms and will always endure a
language it will be what however visual
the net becomes it will still be a
medium of language it will still be a
medium in which people need to use the
language and the people who use the
language well and effectively will
generate more authority than those who
do not make another point on that too
you know I'm after the Iran elections
and there were all the uprisings and
they wouldn't let news organizations in
okay for 50 years our idea of the most
compelling way of telling a story in
real time has been the television clip
right it's it's the guy standing in
front of the tank and
square it's incredibly compelling we go
to text back clean up to find out what
it's what it all means and to make the
associations and set the context right
so you get to these these uprisings and
there is no really is no no television
and what you have is people started
twittering and at the height of it there
were 2,500 tweets a minute coming out
and what was really kind of interesting
to me about that is that the reality of
television and that compelling visual
image is you got the 42nd clip that you
want to see but then you got four hours
of Wolf Blitzer droning on and on and on
and on and on and it's really boring and
you can't fast-forward you can't pick
the pieces that you like however what
happened with with twitter is that
people started posting videos and
started posting pictures and other
people started sorting them into ah
here's the good stuff here ah here's a
report over here and what you could do
is because text is scannable and you can
go through and you can find out the
parts that are interesting to you it
ended up being a much more compelling
way of telling a story in real time
because you could pick the videos you
wanted you could pick the pictures that
you wanted and you could sort of
impressionistic alee at least see what
was you know see the main currents of
what was going on so it may be
ultimately that text reasserts itself in
terms of that real-time kind of a way to
cover something
seven the executive director of
stagesource which is the greater boston
feeder alliance and for the last 18
months or so i've been working with some
colleagues here in Boston assessing the
state of Boston arts journalism in the
hopes to find an online arts journal
solution some sort of model that would
exist for the Greater Boston Arts arts
and cultural community and so I'm
curious Doug about your the summit that
you organized and hosted and you'd
mentioned in your marks earlier that
there doesn't seem to be a business
model out there that exists and I wonder
what who's doing work in this area to
assess it to do some research around
this who's talking about this was there
any sort of next steps that came out of
the summit in terms of this should be a
priority one concern we have here in
greater boston or we had a big scare
this year was that the boston globe are
you know primary newsprint source for
arts and cultural coverage and you know
the threat was that it was going to go
away I know in Seattle the is the
post-intelligencer that's no longer in
print and so I'm curious really about
some ideas and who's who is talking
about this in terms of the future for
models and opportunities first I should
say that there are lots of models out
there that actually are making money I
mean Boing Boing sells millions of
dollars worth of ads a year think last
year is over two million dollars on the
three people who write that's a model
that makes money Talking Points Memo
started as a one-person blog josh mike
marshall now has something like 21
reporters that they're hiring that's a
model that works politico's is a model
that works I mean there are starting to
be a lot of models that work here's the
problem in the arts is that the
readership the the eyeballs that you can
attract are going to be smaller than the
big political blog
I mean it's just a way that it works the
genius of newspapers originally was that
you aggregated all sorts of niches for
which you couldn't have a daily you know
you couldn't publish a daily crossword
puzzle as you know the economics
wouldn't work out but bundle that with
this and this and this and this and this
the reality is is that people aren't
buying the newspaper for four brilliant
coverage of City Hall even though they
appreciate that it's there and they will
read it so you have to find you know
that the news business has always been a
subsidized business you know York the
cost of your subscription barely pays
for the the printing and the delivery
costs doesn't pay for the the news
gathering part of it so most of the
solutions most of the things that people
have been trying in terms of arts have
been very traditional in the sense of
will will hire reviewers or will get
citizenry critics and we'll put it
online well the reality is when you
start looking at all of those sites is
that if they get more than a couple
hundred people a day that's pretty
amazing and the fact is is that you
cannot sell and not advertising on a
site like that to make it work the
current CPM rate if you're really wildly
successful is you know I mean the
average out there is about 41 cents
that's you get 41 cents for every
thousand times the NAD has shown if
you're really lucky you'll get five
dollars right but but some of these
sites some of these sort of Metro sites
they say that they need about eighteen
dollars to be able to make it so it you
know so then you go down the other route
is it going to be a non-profit and so do
you incorporate and try and be well that
creates a whole other set of things that
you got to deal with which is is is not
necessarily going to get you there
either although it might I mean no there
there are lots of people there are lots
of people trying lots of sites trying it
so for me the challenge is is how do you
network and aggregate enough readership
to be able to build a community that's
sufficiently large enough against which
you can create a number of revenue
sources whether it's live events whether
it's added kind of ticket sale kind of
thing where whether it's memberships
whether it's subscriptions whether it's
you know I mean all all of these things
and until you get to five or ten or
fifteen or twenty thousand people a day
you can't even start to go there the the
universe of people who actually want to
advertise to that group is is pretty
small now I will say that the Milwaukee
Journal Sentinel just laid off a good
number of its arts writers only the
visual art writers next the classical
music critic went to the venues which he
had been covering and said hey you know
why are you spending $300,000
advertising in the newspaper when
they're not going to cover you anymore
come join my thing and throw us a third
of that and and we're there for you so I
do think that there's a way in which
arts organizations cultural
organizations everybody's talking about
this right now what are we going to do
and they're all approaching it in now
with with in a variety of ways but I
think that if you were able to get a
bunch of them together that you'd find
some some audience some willingness to
advertise and to support something one
of the problems i think that dog is
talking about here has to do with the
conflict between the global and the
local or the national and a local there
it seems to me it's clear in some degree
that the web has already demonstrated
that because of its global reach it can
create communities that are not
localized the problem is that if you're
talking about arts journalism of the
sort our panel has been interested in
local arts communities local arts
organizations are only marginally helped
if there's a journal that talks about
dance across the world or dance away
across the United States so I think
there is a kind of
national audience for poetry for dance
for drama criticism the prophet the prop
the problem has to do with the way in
which all of these activities are also
localized in a way that requires support
requires audiences and I think the real
question is whether or not the web is
going to be viable as a as an
environment to create these local
communities as against the national
communities and 11 footnote to what Doug
was saying again I know about slate
because I know about Robert Pinsky is a
friend of mine is talk to me about his
problems at slate one of the reasons
that Pinsky went to the tradition of
once a month doing a poem out of the
public domain so that in the public
domain so he could publish it without
pay is that he wants to pay his poets
but of course slate counts the number of
hits that come to each section of slate
and guess what part of slate gets the
smallest number of hits the poetry so in
order to preserve the poetry presents on
slate one of the things Pinsky did was
he said okay three times a month I'll
have living poets and I'll pay them
something for their contribution and
I'll use free poets who may actually
also incidentally be much greater poets
and will generate a discussion about
them and it's still not clear I mean I
think he's quite worried about this and
since I've mentioned it let me encourage
all of you if you just go on to the site
and look at what's there you'll be
helping poetry on Slate because if
you're there if there's a hit just
looking at the poem you don't even have
to read it if you if you click on it
that counts and you know I've been
encouraging my students to do the same
let me let me add just one other issue
too is she said the you know Boston
Globe could go out of business you know
there is a school of thought and i'm not
going to fess up whether i subscribe to
this or not but you can probably guess
what newspapers for a long time pretty
much ignored the internet I mean they
think they kind of did the absolute
minimum kind of thing that they could do
and they put very few resources into it
they also had this ad base for print ads
that was wildly over inflated and based
on on this idea of a monopoly in a
market you can claim greater reach with
a newspaper than anything else so their
way of dealing one of the ways in which
they
you have dealt with the news with online
is they'll say oh you know by this
really overinflated price print ad and
we'll throw in the online ad for next to
nothing thereby establishing the value
of the online ad as as being really
really low now imagine that the i won't
say Boston because but imagine the
Seattle Times now goes out of business
after the post-intelligencer is and
there is predict there are predictions
that within a year at least a couple of
major American cities will be without a
daily I would suggest that if that goes
away the ad rate will climb in those
communities possibly to a point where it
would be sustainable certainly to do
more than then is what what is happening
right now but right now we're in this
kind of you know period of artificial
dis inflation for for ads the other
thing is and this is this is sort of
disheartening is that when when you look
at how people click on ads you know
eight percent of the audience out there
clicks on eighty percent of the ads
that's a very small group and even
though we can very specifically target
where you are both geographically and
demographically now unfortunately the
people who come to news sites and you
can conjecture all you want for the
reasons for this they click on ads at a
significantly lower rate than they do on
regular website on other websites so
people who are going someplace for news
they want that they don't want to be
interrupted by the ads so there is
greater resistance so that the
click-through rate on ads on new sites
is you know one tenth of one percent
that is makes it a hard a hard thing to
to sell hi my name is Gracie and I
always curious about the idea of if you
know of examples I mean you talk about
PO writing his own reviews you talked
about you know active poets on Pinsky's
column
contributing are there examples of
artists of creators of dancers of poets
creating content and then encouraging
critical review and then engaging that
and trying to build a community around
the criticism of their work are you
seeing that anywhere I'm not engaging
with fans but actually trying to engage
active criticism of themselves zero I
think there are there have been examples
of this I guess is that some of my some
of Mike's EMS students might have better
examples and I then I know but I seem to
recall that Stephen King began to
publish a book on the on the web and
waited for responses encouraged
responses from his audience before he
can continued it and I remember reading
articles about this as if it was a you
know a really sort of a radical
transformation I think it didn't have
that impact that was what number of
people who would buy oh yeah oh it does
that would pay right that's it that's
the fan base yes I saw it's certainly a
good idea but I'm not aware of all I
think it's good idea i may baby does to
wear them i haven't seen anything like
what you're describing where you know
someone is actively engaging with with
criticism of their own work online
although i've seen bits and pieces of it
when they've responded to comments but i
haven't seen it can I don't know they
may be there I haven't seen continuing
caught you know critical conversations
there are actually a lot of sites out
there like that go to e harlequin
dot-com you know Harlequin romances
right they've created this amazing
community where you can upload pieces of
your book I mean everybody thinks they
got a trashy novel in them right but
it's a way of interacting both getting
criticism but also you get to work with
their writers and they tell you you know
what's effective and what's not
effective you know pitchfork has had
Hichborn it's in music has a lot of sort
of interaction and there are lots of
you're going to tell us about a couple
more yeah good yeah I've been waiting
for for there are many many places in
which authors actually interact not just
with fans but with with other people
mostly I think because there are more
and more authors coming out of writing
online which i think is a fantastic
thing as Professor throw Bernardino's um
for instance Naomi Novik who writes a
fairly pas
you know this is mostly sci-fi and
fantasy authors largely speaking not
necessarily interacting with fans though
but with everybody who is in a
conversation about this because whenever
you say sci-fi and fantasy people go oh
those nutty fans at those conventions
well that's part of it but but not all
and who else god I can't even think of
how I can't even think of who I should
say because there are so many people IE
Harlequin is a great thing but also
elsewhere in the romance world there's
huge conversations which is funny
because people say oh the romance novel
world there so there's onra there so the
same thing nobody really cares about
what's in it well yeah there's onra but
people care about different things
within that you know they aren't trying
to make higher anyway games well amazing
sort of gaming well we've said nothing
about games allow people in the audience
who know a lot about it and we've really
said nothing about fan communities which
although flourish has been employing it
and of course fan communities are an
incredibly creative environment in which
people are collaborating and creating
all kinds of SAR not necessarily purely
you know sycophantic talking to the mic
because you don't know the live arts
dance theatre music it's more difficult
because you're you're sort of going
against what the you know live art I
mean you're actually one step removed by
projecting it on you know YouTube or
whatever unless you're live casting it
which is a which is quite different to
think well there are sites like the
winger for instance which is started by
a new york city ballet dancer and now
has dancers from all over the world and
they interact and they talk about each
other's work and but that's not i mean
we are talking about critical discourse
here and as such that does raise another
problem you know where you're going to
act when you're talking out let's say
theatre performances or music or
whatever then you know often you can
find I guess conversations between
artists and with each other artists with
you know with readers or contributors
but they tend to be very sort of bland
and safe and they tend not to have any
real critical evaluative because
everyone wants to key you know no one
wants you know no one wants say any
that's going to be take you know taken
as being too critical so I find them to
be you know I mean I would I find them
often to be somewhat you know somewhat
toothless rather than really getting to
a critical conversation where people can
be respectful but can make real
substantial critical points about an
artist's work and I find them awfully
they're all they're very policed and
sometimes if they're sponsored by or
have ads by very arts organizations that
are spot you know then then that
immediately creates a sort of you know
an ethical barrier and a financial and a
reluctance to to really speak honestly
Frank Phylly and you know critically hi
I'm Alicia anstead and I'm the editor of
inside arts magazine and I also oversee
this largely student-driven blog for the
office for the Arts at Harvard and I
teach art journal ism also at Harvard
and I'd like to respond to a number of
things that you've said first of all we
haven't really talked about the crisis
that we're in and I think that those of
us who come out of traditional
journalism have been going crazy trying
to figure out how to make a living for
the last five or so years so the other
thing I want to say is Doug thank you
and congratulations for the work that
you do are an arts journal it's it's
been a model for a lot of us and also a
home base for a lot of us and for the
summit too and I was one of the ones who
tweeted that you look like Al Franken
and I would like to say evaluative Lee
you're better looking so I apologize
that that seemed to shake you up a
little bit but in in response to what
you were saying what you were saying
about artists and where are they in this
conversation I think that this is a real
opportunity for those of us who have the
skills to talk with artists who are used
to being the arbiters and the mediators
that that this is a place where our
voice is still valuable and it may have
to be at conferences it may have to be
in forums that are outside of what we're
comfortable with but I think that there
is a place for the traditional arts
journalists to take his or her skills
and apply them in a new way out in the
world this blog that I'm running
is one of those ways we're not trying to
do arts criticism we're trying to build
an arts community and inevitably there's
some critical thought that goes into the
work that we do so I I wanted to say
that it's not criticism what is it what
how are you building the community so
what I have five student bloggers all of
whom have some background just in their
own lives one is a musician one it has
it seems to have incredible experience
out in the world of the arts one is a
writer and one belongs to the Harvard
music world and they simply go out into
their worlds and they come back to me
and this is this is why my role is this
is the only role that I can play for
them is to say let's do this let how can
I support you in doing this how can i
give you the technology they go out into
the community of harvard and beyond and
they find the stories they come back and
they have there are rules they're not
allowed to write over 200 words and
they're encouraged to use every type of
technology they can come up with and
it's it's very new but we're developing
it and we're always when they go up it
might be just a report on some new
project some new art project might just
be our quote or on description of a
panel like this and well I I'd be
delighted to put it on the screen I
don't know are you are you lie I don't
know if I don't know if you see if you
see if you are so and the other you know
the other thing is I jump in office for
the Arts you have to go to the office
for the Arts at Harvard that's the entry
point I don't know Doug well we won't
search for it okay I mean you'd have to
search for it because it's dated so
funny lots of funny but you know I jump
in from time to time to like for
instance on Saturday night Frank riches
interviewing Stephen Sondheim at sanders
theatre and Frank Rich is a Harvard grad
so that's our angle and Frank Rich was
kind enough to agree to do an interview
either with a student or with me and it
turns out I happen to
that one but I jump into and
occasionally at a professional voice
sometimes that leans a little bit more
toward criticism sometimes it doesn't
you know I got to tell you I got bored
writing reviews i wrote for 20 years for
the Bangor Daily News in Maine and main
contrary to its a very bad behavior
recently it's a great art state and I
got to see world-class acts there and
write about them and it was very
exciting but you know what I'm kind of
interested in a different thing now I'm
interested in this chaotic world that
that were in and one of the one of one
of my hats that I wear as a very
traditional as Doug knows a very
traditional magazine about the Arts it
covers the arts industry and we're also
seeing many arts people arts
administrators hiring not many I wish it
were many that was an overstatement and
dream thinking really looking to arch
journalists to see if there are ways
where they can join the organization
become part of building community around
the arts and I think that may be the
model so let me just ask a couple just
my questions actually I'm sorry to take
up so much time but Doug I want to ask
you what excites you about what's going
on right now and um bill I want to ask
you do you pay your writers and how do
you pick your writers how does your how
does your site pay for itself and are
you interested in more diversity than
we're seeing on this panel tonight thank
you you want to start oh that's well I
don't most of the writers that are
writing for our trees that are not
getting paid at the moment no there was
one reason that i've incorporated to
become a non-profit is because I've been
feeling that I do want to pay my writers
and so the attempt is to try to find
some sort of model where you know i'm
not going to become a millionaire
overnight or in a week about to be able
to pay right or something for what they
do because i was a freelancer for a
number of newspapers in the area for you
know over 20 years and i would
ordinarily i would be paid for what I'd
done so I ultimately although people
were doing things for free I and they
were doing good things for free because
of high quality writing I
that I wanted to pay them for it so
that's part of what the whole process of
becoming a non-profit and exploring that
idea in terms of in terms of payment so
and just so you just mention something
about becoming tired as a critic so let
me just say that uh in the history of
criticism generally you know
particularly really most of the really
good critics were not critics for a long
period of time they did not just have a
career where they were you know they did
it for 20 30 whatever number of decades
of people like Shaw and others you know
George Bernard Shaw well it's only a
critic for four years kenneth tynan also
is not a critic for a very long period
of time so this could be and I'm sort of
arguing against myself here you know
this could be a profession where one can
flame out you know after a series of
years and you do become sort of tired of
it because you do lose the freshness of
approach that you have when you first
you first come so what excites me myself
is the question that the student asked
her earlier and that is I am interested
in ways in which one can take the values
of the past and somehow bring them into
the future to the chaos that we find
today and look for ways in which people
can reimbursed for writing evaluative
Lee critically about the arts because
what i mean when one other things that
you've mentioned that and we sort of
touched on it and that is set for a lot
of what's going on in terms of arts
writing you're saying well sometimes
some critical thinking creeps in and
sometimes not and sometimes they come
back with a story and sometimes with a
quotation well you know I mean that is
that's sort of what was happening in the
80s and the 90s I mentioned The New
Yorker in the melding of feature writing
and reviewing and that is those lines
become blurred right and as they become
blurred then the idea of what is
evaluative writing you know because
begins the somewhat fade or weaken
because an interview a story is seen as
a form of evaluation you know I've done
a review and I think that that you know
you do have to serve as you bring the
past into the present you do have to
keep in mind that you do want to try to
keep that this discriminate between
those those forms of looking and writing
about the arts or at least make people
aware of the fact that they're fusing
them together and that and that they do
have separate lives and separate
histories so just a couple of numbers in
the last three years 50
Sandoval staff arts jobs have
disappeared and they're not a newspaper
in the newspaper yeah yeah yeah but
actually you can probably apply it I
mean because because most arts
journalism jobs were in newspapers for a
long time and and but that that's not
something that's really new it's just an
acceleration frankly when the national
arts journalism program began back in
1994 about ninety percent of everybody
who applied we're staff writers and that
was the the norm in fact they didn't
even think about taking freelancers back
then this is the pew program in arts
journalism by the time the program
closed in 2005 it completely flipped
around ninety percent were freelancers
and it's a trend that has has has gone
for a long time and you know if you look
if you look out there in other American
cities not you know not the really major
ones but sort of the second here like
Minneapolis and like Seattle and you
know you know those newspaper jobs were
pretty well I mean pretty good gigs to
get and so what you saw was people would
roost in them for decades long after
they really had anything really
significant to to clock about so um you
want to continue that way it used to be
that the newspaper that the book review
order for the or the movie reviewer on a
newspaper was a guy who was too old to
cover the police beat anymore so they
gay so they gave him the arts beat and
that happened when I was a young
reporter on the Newark news 45 years ago
so what excites me I actually find this
incredibly exciting time I I think that
periods where everything is static and
you know you know if you do this thing
and then that gets you to that thing and
you know there's like these tubes that
lead to success and
just sort of you know inch your way up
the tubes that's really i mean it's it's
a lot easier in a way but it's not very
interesting and I think we're in just
this amazing period and I think we're
coming upon the Golden Age of arts
journalism if you will partly because I
I do think that a lot of the ways in
which we have discussed culture in this
country in this country has been really
stunted you know public discourse on
culture in this country we haven't had
much of that for 4 30 40 years you know
it is when you can say oh we have
critics and newspapers but as you know
those are lone voices and sometimes
they're not very good voices and you
know watch every time there was any sort
of culture story that was the least
controversial it would get polarized
really fast and we don't know how to
talk about culture in very interesting
ways so I find it really really
interesting that people are diving in
and wanting to talk about culture now it
also means that our our definition of
and the things that we're paying
attention to in culture are diversifying
in pretty amazing ways I mean you know
somebody i guess it was you mention you
know it's like three old white guys up
here right this is not what culture is
right now you know the mold okay well
i'll put myself in that but the but but
the thing is is that you know definition
of what is good you know after
post-modernism that's a really difficult
thing to kind of wrap your arms around
the definition of standards it's really
difficult thing to wrap your arms around
these days so suddenly to have all of
this kind of activity bubbling up and
this morass of information that we're
just swamped by which everybody is
intimidated by which everybody is is
trying struggling trying to figure out
how to cope with it you know it's the
age of the curator we all have to find
people whom we grow to trust
who have authoritative voices and can
put things into some sort of frameworks
in which we understand and hopefully you
know in a better cultural kind of lens
then we're used to talking about culture
in this way because I don't think we've
done this very well and I think that
what's coming is just a lot more
interesting do you think it will also be
far more democratic and interactive than
previous models Oh unquestionably we
know that for sure if I think you can
easily predict a lot of a lot of other
things are very unpredictable I would
predict the interactivity will be a
crucial part of where arts journalism is
going to go in the future definitely
every few weeks there's something that
happens that I go oh god that changes
everything you know like right now I i
I'm I'm I'm just you know my whole world
is shaken from what Twitter did last
week right what Twitter did last week
was that allowed all of its users to
make lists and that you can follow lists
right now imagine this if you're a news
organization you know what if you were
able to and they now geocode everything
right so what if you were to define your
geographical region and you were able to
capture all of the Twitter accounts
right and you can monitor in in real
time and you could assign by lists what
various people are tweeting about you
could want to turn in real time you'd
see a bloom of tweets happening when
something would happen and you could
delve into these things instead of
having a team of 30 reporters or 200
reporters you've now got a team of a
hundred thousand reporters who can do
something okay so I'm thinking okay as
somebody who aggregates stories for a
living who goes out and looks at all of
these things you know god I'm pretty
boring compared to most people you know
to a lot of people out there the
aggregate number of people out there so
I have to really completely rethink what
it means to be an aggregator or what it
means to be a reporter or what it means
in fact to cover an area in some way and
and just this idea of having lists where
you could you know add up everybody
who's interesting on
topic and add in and add out and have
people follow that I think is a complete
game changer for how we cover news
because you can do it in multimedia now
how would you do it in the arts oh I'm
already I'm already working on that
which is you know find all the people
who are talking about in music in a
really interesting way make it porous
enough so that you can put people on and
off the listen in an easy fashion and
and then start running the feeds in
various levels of curation do it for
blogs the other way could have been
specific to couldn't you avoid you who's
going to see this movie too absolutely
absolutely I mean that this makes
everybody out there or reporter doesn't
make everybody an equal reporter and
that's ultimately in a sense where I
think you need journalists which who are
making news judgments for what's
important and what's not important but
that will be based more from being the
center of a community rather than being
at the top of a pyramid thank the
audience
you